würdest du dich als empathischen
menschen bezeichnen ob ja oder nein nach
diesem video wirst du vielleicht anders
darüber denken
vor etwa einem erhielte hierbei schön
schlau ein flammendes plädoyer für mehr
empathie mit dem argument dass empathie
ein bemerkenswertes produkt unserer
evolution ist und eine wichtige
grundlage für unser soziales
zusammenbricht und dass empathie uns
erst zum menschen macht uns von tieren
unterscheidet aber eins haben uns die
tiere voraus und zwar sie handeln immer
logisch selbst wenn sie kein verständnis
für logik haben sie tun was sie tun
müssen um nahrung zu besorgen um ihren
nachwuchs zu schützen um zu überleben
der mensch aber kann rational aber auch
ziemlich irrational handeln und empathie
ist ein grund heute widmen wir uns also
mal der dunklen seite der empathie in
80er jahren wurde die empathie
altruismus hypothese populär
sprich empathie also unsere fähigkeit
uns in andere menschen hineinzuversetzen
mit mitzufühlen fördert altruismus also
das selbstlose einsätzen für das
wohlergehen unserer mitmenschen kurz
empathie gleich hilfsbereit
doch das stimmt nicht immer stellt euch
vor ihr seid shoppen in der
fußgängerzone dann sitzt da ein alter
mann mit amputierten beinen traurigen
gesicht und bäche nach geld ganz ehrlich
wie viele von euch schauen da lieber weg
es ist nichts ungewöhnliches sich bei
einem solchen amt abzuwenden aber der
grund dafür ist nicht dass wir
gefühlskalt sind sondern genau das
gegenteil unsere empathie unser
mitgefühl kann es leicht überfordern
diese überforderung kann dazu führen
dass wir uns moralisch fragwürdig war
wir helfen den bettler nicht nur nicht
sondern wir schaffen es noch nicht mal
ihn an zuschaut wenn mitfühlen zu
mitleiden geht kommt es zu sogenannten
empathischen stress der ist berufsalltag
für krankenpfleger ärzte therapeuten
oder sozialarbeiter wie geht man damit
um nicht selten mit gleichgültigkeit bis
hin zu zynismus aber wenn man sich
anschaut die empathie im gehirn entsteht
sieht man dass man nicht zwingend mit
fühlen muss um nachzuvollziehen was ein
anderer mensch denkt man unterscheidet
zwischen empathischen mit bühnen und
mentalität
wenn ich metallisierte dann denke ich
darüber nach was du denkst was weißt du
was du hast doch vor wie könnte ich das
beeinflussen wer unsere videos zur
dunklen triade gesehen ist vor allem das
zum materialismus der weiß dass ein in
partien loser manipulativer mensch dazu
in der lage sein kann einem mitmenschen
genau das zu sagen was wir hören möchte
dafür muss man dazu in der lage sein
nachzuvollziehen was der andere denkt
und fühlt das heißt aber nicht zwingend
dass man mit fühlen muss empathisches
mitfühlen und vitalisierende sind sogar
neuronal unterscheiden
beim emotionalen mitfühlen werden andere
gehirnregionen aktiv als beim ich sag
mal gedanklichen perspektivenwechsel
apropos die triade der psychologe paul
blumen geht noch einen schritt weiter er
behauptet dass psychopathen nicht an
einem mangel an empathie leihen sondern
möglicherweise an einer krankhaften
sucht danach nehmen wir einen sadisten
der freude am leid eines anderen
verspürt dann ist das ja so weil er sich
so gut in das leid des anderen menschen
hineinfühlen kann und empathie hat noch
eine kehrseite die ganz eng mit ihren
positiven folgen verknüpft ist das ist
ganz natürlich dass wir mit menschen die
uns ehrlich sind viel besser mitfühlen
können als mit menschen mit denen wir
wenig gemeinsam haben
die folge ist dass wir andere menschen
ausgrenzen oder abwertend die nicht zu
unserer eigenen gruppe gehört außerdem
macht uns etwa die oft unglaublich ihrer
zimmer zum beispiel ist es nicht
ungewöhnlich dass unser schicksal eines
einzelnen menschen stärker berührt als
das von vielen wenn hunderte flüchtlinge
im mittelmeer ertrinken dann bewegt dass
menschen weniger als ein foto eines
einzelnen junge der tot am strand liegt
in aigen außerdem dazu unser mitgefühl
vor allem underdogs und außenseitern zu
geben mit ein grund dafür dass trump
sich in seinem wahlkampf als opfer des
establishments und der fake news
das mit viel mit opfern wird auf die
spitze getrieben in der art und weise
wie wir mit tieren mitfühlen nach
unserem verständnis sind ihre unschuldig
die verfolgen keine unmoralischen
absichten außer das überleben so kann
man immer wieder beobachten dass
menschen von schicksalen einzelner tiere
stärker bewegt werden als zum beispiel
vom krieg in syrien sei es der gorilla
haram b für den anschein manche liebe
ein kind hätten sterben sehen oder der
löwel sessel der jimmy kimmel vor
laufender kamera zum weinen brachte
rational ist was anderes also nicht dass
ich nicht traurig bin darüber dass ein
zahnarzt zu seiner eigenen belustigung
löwen tötet aber wenn man darüber weint
müsste man rational gesehen nonstop wein
über das ganze leid dass tagtäglich in
der welt passiert mal ganz abgesehen von
der irrationalität dass viele menschen
sich von schicksalen einzelner tiere
bewegen lassen ohne gewissensbisse
fleisch essen jedenfalls empathie ist
etwas unglaublich faszinierendes das uns
menschen zu menschen macht das heißt
aber gleichzeitig dass es nicht zwingend
etwas gutes ist empathie für anlass uns
dazu anderen menschen zu helfen sie
veranlasst uns aber auch dazu
wegzuschauen und wenn wir nicht
aufpassen verschenken wir unser
mitgefühl dahin wo es rational gesehen
nicht unbedingt am meisten gebraucht
wird es kommt also immer darauf an wie
wir unser mitgefühl einsetzen
ein soziales leben ohne empathie ist und
denkt war aber ohne rationales denken
sind ihr garantiert schlimmer als unsere
tierischen freunde
das wichtige ist also eine gute balance
wie so oft im leben also setzt er mit
gefühl und verstand gleichermaßen schlau
ein schön schlau zum beispiel
damit würde ich euch wunderschöne
feiertage und einen guten rutsch ins
neue jahr den wir machen zwei wochen
winterpause wir sehen uns also erst 2018
bis dahin könnt ihr gerne alle eure
fragen für das neue jahr in die
kommentare schreiben
wir sehen uns im
design bleibt sicher